podcasts that cover current events and
news are some of the most popular in the
world
people love knowing about the
astonishing occurrences of the dying
world around them
will sasso i have prepared the following
news items for you to read in the voice
of hulk hogan this is infomania begin
what a way to come back to this dude
i i mean your hulk hogan and your
schwarzenegger i love all your
impersonations of course
but hogan and schwarzenegger are like
easily my favorite so i'm i'm very
excited to hear you doing smith yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay let's do
it
let's do
infomania yeah are you are you getting
into hogan by doing well yeah yeah yeah
yeah listen this is how you do in for
mania you have to do
the hulk hogan voice don't do this
don't do this yeah come on it's a social
happening oh
all right
[ __ ] information we've done infomania
i think
two or three other times maybe yeah it's
a fun bit
here we go
i like this one there's also some crazy
[ __ ] news that's been going on you'll
be covering some of that sure
all right infomania all right here we go
let's see what doozy is going to do well
let me tell you something about social
media brother elon musk was going to buy
twitter dude but he backed out of the
deal brother
so twitter suing him to try to make him
go through with it brother when twitter
first started dude you couldn't even put
pictures on it but now you can dude
because it's a different time brother
okay
that's social media dude that's some
good reporting hulk yep that's uh that's
the first news story that uh
yeah well let me go hold on a second
chad that was the news dude but now i
got an editorial comment dude that
usually didn't provide for us brother
you know let me tell you something about
elon musk dude he's been feuding with
that down low and dirty donald trump
brother and it's on twitter dude if you
can remember
donald trump
uh
he hosted wrestlemania's four and five
at that did he really yeah piece of [ __ ]
uh
trump plaza brother and and and in
wrestlemania five dude that's when the
mega powers exploded brother
all right
that was a different time dude yeah
brother that was a different time dude
that would have been 1989 or something
like that dude
in 1989 dude that's a different time
brother
they shook
hands oh my god
okay yeah it's a different time dude
well let me tell you something about
space dude it's so big that we can't
even see the other side of it brother
that's why we have telescopes dude they
can see all the way past the planets and
the solar system out into the universe
brother
but the best
telescope we use
hold on a second dude the best telescope
we had used to be the hubble dude but
now we got the james webb space
telescope brother and it's slamming that
hubble down just like i did andre the
giant for a 93 173 screaming alkamaniacs
in the pontiac silverdome pontiac
michigan brother
not the superdome chad right the silver
dome
my uncle rodney had a telescope when i
was a kid and he let me look through it
sometimes dude it was in his backyard
next to a pile of old tvs brother my
aunt linda hated those tvs dude
one day she set him on fire brother
they both died a few years ago dude
they didn't have any kids brother
that's space
does that
is that true for you at all is that hulk
hogan is that true for him the uncle
rodney and aunt linda and all this [ __ ]
or whatever
your guess is as good as mine i didn't
grow up with a rachel crustacean right
or jennifer neutrino or a gibber
pravallia for that matter but perhaps
hulk hogan has a an uncle rodney all
right well let me tell you something
about pigs brother a bunch of surgeons
a bunch of surgeons recently
transplanted a pig's heart into the
chest of two brain dead people dude they
kept their bodies alive for three days
brother and that helped these doctors
learn a lot about future pig to human
transplants dude pig genitalia are the
closest of any other animal on the
planet to human genitalia brother
that's what a hot dog is dude pigs
that's not true well hold on a second
dude yeah dude that was the news but i
have an editorial comment about that
dude is it hot dogs can be made out of
other things brother yeah yeah you don't
even eat meat dude not anymore brother
yeah well hold on chad hogan which is
just a half-ass hulk hogan hold on a
second dude
yeah about that brother hold on
underwater pretty good dude yeah hold on
underwater chad culture and because
here's the thing dude you could also
make a beef hot dog brother or you could
make it out of tofu dude that's no beef
at all dude and if you said where's the
beef and you had a chicken dog well
that there would be no beef at all dude
cause that's a chicken brother and
that's the difference between two
animals dude
okay let me tell you something about
science dude
they turned on the large hadron collider
again brother i don't know we all know
last time they turned it on they
discovered the higgs boson dude this
time they discovered some more things
brother they found a new pentaquark dude
and
hold on dude
i said nothing
dude i'm holding
hold on chad okay
hold on a minute dude
i'm trying to get through the news here
dude
and there's some new words brother and i
don't know my good friend chad colts
riding on the back of that red and
yellow harley he might be able to tell
you if pen quark is an actual thing or
if it's just nothing like
jennifer neutrino dude no so far this
this is an accurate news story hold on a
second dude i'm trying to read the news
brother that's why it's called infomania
not chad hogan uh uh mania brother they
found a new pentaquark dude and two new
tetra quarks brother
penta dude
tantra brother
penta dude
tantra dude
quarks brother those are hadrons dude
but they're not bozens brother higbosins
or bozens dude pentaquarks are hadrons
brother but not bozens dude bozens are
bozon's brother
hadrian's are hadrian's dude
that's science
you really cleared that out
oh my god that's a good news story oh
it's [ __ ] great okay we got one more
here here we go let me tell you
something about music brother to
celebrate the release of her new single
beyonce made her first ever tick tock
dude
beyonce brother
beyonce dude
beyonce brother beyonce dude everyone
loves her since she debuted beyonce
brother beyonce dude tires made of
rubber rubber from crood beyonce brother
beyonce dude when's dinner father i want
some food beyonce brother beyonce dude
you need a lawyer if you get sued
beyonce brother beyonce dude you're a
good drummer you have improved beyonce
brother beyonce dude don't mean to
bother let me conclude beyonce brother
beyonce dude beyonce brother beyonce
dude beyonce brother beyonce dude
that's music
oh my god dude
[Music]
thank you moving on holy [ __ ] can you
imagine a news anchor doing that
the beyonce brother beyonce dude i think
that's the craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen
someday when dudesy has its own uh
24-hour news channel there will be that
yeah and it'll be gibber pravallia the
news desk with gibber provaga yeah and
jennifer neutrino i'd love to uh
crustacean with weather
uh and greg kinkade with sports
and um uh that's exactly what you'll
have you'll have doozy uh you'll have
uh
all sorts of uh
computer
media man sometimes i mean you have to
do delays those weird little poems you
use
these rhyming things yeah
yeah then sometimes your brain shuts
down a little bit
are you having that right now covered
brain
i think i had a little bit of covert
brain actually yeah
please tell a friend
[Music]
[Music]
then